les violences policières sont au centre
de nombreuses affaires cette dernière
semaine
s'ils essaient de se faire entendre
depuis le 11 juin dernier les policiers
ont de nouveau manifesté tout au long de
la semaine
lundi ils étaient 200 derrière le
syndicat alliance pour dénoncer
l'inscription accompagnant une fresque
dédiée adama traoré et georges floyd
dénonçant le racisme et les violences
policières qui fuit pas la fresca en
elle même c'est le symbole de cette
inauguration
bara maire qui se dit républicain ont
donc c'est un message envoyé à la
population qui de montres forme concerne
tous les racistes violente et ce qui
n'est pas le cas
le ministre de l'intérieur a pris le
parti des forces de l'ordre dans la
controverse sur cette fresque christophe
castaner a également tenu à apporter son
soutien aux policiers lors de son
audition jeudi devant la mission
d'information du sénat
comme je l'aï rappelé le 8 juin dernier
seuls les policiers et les gendarmes
sont fondés à faire un usage légitime de
la force
ils sont seuls à être fondés à défendre
l'ordre républicain
alors je le dis alors c'est l'essence
même de leur mission ils doivent
l'accomplir évidemment avec
proportionnalité discernement
exemplarité
mais ils doivent pouvoir l'accomplir
sans peur sans crainte car on ne doit
pas être inquiété pour avoir accompli
son devoir dans le respect des règles
c'est maintenant une habitude pour se
faire entendre les policiers se
réunissent et jettent leurs menottes à
terre c'était le cas vendredi soir
devant le bataclan hier des femmes de
policiers se sont elles aussi mobilisés
devant la préfecture de police de paris
à leurs côtés des dizaines de
manifestants étaient présents pour
défendre la profession contre les
accusations de racisme
la raison pour laquelle nous sommes ici
c'est notre amour
certes pour la république pour leurs
premiers pas de manière égale voter mais
pour la paix pour que chacun puisse
vivre en paix et surtout lutter contre
tous les racismes tous les extrémismes
nous sommes vos amis nous sommes au
protecteur nous sommes les gardiens de
votre paie alors assuré juste auprès de
vos concitoyens
la possibilité pour nous de faire notre
métier en toute sécurité les policiers
sont-ils lâchés par leur ministre et
dénigré par l'opinion publique
c'est en tout cas le sentiment général
parmi ces manifestants